c'est une nuit électorale incertaine
palpitante que viennent de vivre les
Américains il n'y a pas de raz-de-marée
républicain comme annoncé mais le parti
de Donald Trump gagne suffisamment de
siège à la Chambre des représentants
pour la faire basculer la position
d'Agnès au sein du gouvernement n'était
pas fragilisé
écoutez aujourd'hui situation non parce
que aujourd'hui les mécanismes
démocratiques sont en place donc
aujourd'hui cette situation n'a pas à
être fragilisée le Sénat lui reste au
coude à coude il faut attendre les
derniers recontacent dans quatre états
pour savoir qui le contrôlera pour moi
c'est pas une tempête dans un verre
d'eau c'est grave la différence entre
l'optimisation fiscale et l'évasion
fiscale c'est l'épaisseur d'un mur de
prison et j'ai pas d'autres commentaires
à faire est-ce qu'elle aurait dû au
moins le signaler de façon préventive à
la Haute Autorité j'ai pas d'autres
commentaires à faire concernant ces
déclarations et je vous renvoie à la
ligne de défense qui est la sienne et
qui est je le redis a eu l'occasion
d'être expliqué il applaudi par les
commentaires de la majorité du
gouvernement est menacé ou pas j'ai pas
lieu de le penser on a là un ministre
qui illustre la porosité qu'il y a entre
le monde économique
ces grandes entreprises et la politique
et ça ça dégoûte les français Emmanuel
Macron doit officiellement annoncer la
fin de l'opération barkhane au Sahel
puisque le président de la République
est en déplacement à Toulon pour
présenter la nouvelle revue nationale
stratégique l'Europe en effet n'est
désormais plus à l'abri de frappes de
missiles de drones et nous devons
intégrer cette réalité car la
technologie m'est désormais à la
disposition d'adversaires qui ne sont
pas toujours des états les moyens de
frapper à distance grosse frayeur pour
les services de sécurité du roi Charles
III ont déplacement à New York camilia
le roi a été pris pour cible lors d'un
bain de foule par un individu qui vous
le voyez à lancer des œufs le bateau et
ses 234 rescapés à bord font désormais
route vers la France
depuis 19 jours et les premiers
sauvetages lotion Viking s'est vu
refuser 43 fois l'accès à un port à
Malte d'abord puis en Italie il risque
d'y avoir des morts parce que il manque
d'alimentation d'eau ils arrivent au
bout et si demain ça arrive que va-t-on
dire partout on va s'émouvoir on va les
accueillir on préfère accueillir les
tombes il faut l'accueillir ou pas ce
bateau il faut l'accueillir aujourd'hui
et il faut pas sortir
bien entendu donc vous demandez à
Emmanuel Macron très vite de prendre une
décision parce qu'on a pas de décision
c'est Darmanin s'est engagé vendredi
matin depuis rien à bouger ce bateau il
a vocation est accueilli en Italie
l'attitude actuelle du gouvernement
italien et notamment les déclarations et
le refus de laisser à Coster ce bateau
à contrario de toutes les règles
européennes qui ont été acceptées par
l'ensemble des pays de l'Union est
inacceptable dans un communiqué la
présidente du gouvernement italien
remercie la France
nous exprimons notre reconnaissance
envers la France de partager la
responsabilité de l'urgence migratoire
jusqu'ici reposant sur les seules
épaules de l'Italie et d'autres pays
européens je vous dis que la vérité
par les États européens qui engagent
également l'Italie qui perçoit des fonds
pour cela et qui relèvent d'un mécanisme
humanitaire de solidarité européenne
accueillir un bateau ça veut dire en
accueillir 10 et ça envoie un message à
mon avis qui est dramatique et qui
invite ces personnes à tenter l'aventure
dans la Méditerranée et donc à risquer
des morts après on fait pas caponor mais
on met cap au Sud
humainement fermement ces gens doux on
sait très bien d'où ils partent ce sont
des ports tunisiens des ports libyens il
était de notre honneur et que l'honneur
de la France commandait d'accueillir la
chaîne Viking ici en France si ça
s'avérait nécessaire Marseille qui est
un port et qui a cette tradition serait
en capacité est en capacité de les
accueillir
il y a des gens à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres de la Corse qui risque leur
vie que je sois autorisé ou pas à le
faire je les accueillerai trois naviront
eux obtenus l'autorisation d'accoster
dans les ports italiens le humanity one
le rise of Lego barrent Rome n'a
toutefois permis qu'à une partie des
migrants de descendre à quai au grand
dames désorganisation humanitaires